Jede Minute werden auf YouTube
400 Stunden Videomaterial hochgeladen.
103 Millionen Spam-Mails
landen täglich in unseren Postfächern.
Und auf Twitter werden
rund 500 Millionen Tweets versendet.
Das sind 6000 Tweets pro Sekunde.
Kein Menschenleben reicht aus,
um das alles zu verarbeiten.
Im Dauerfeuer an Geschichten,
Bildern und verführerischen Angeboten
fühlt sich manch einer überfordert –
es herrscht Information Overload.
Doch wie kommt die schiere Masse
von Informationen überhaupt zustande?
Durch die schnelle Taktung,
in der neue Informationen hergestellt werden,
steigt der Druck auf alle,
selbst neue Inhalte zu produzieren.
Zeitungen etwa aktualisieren
ihre Seiten im Stundentakt.
Etwas weltweit zu publizieren,
ist leicht geworden.
Jeder kann ein Video drehen und hochladen.
Außerdem nehmen
die Nachrichtenkanäle ständig zu.
Zu viele Informationen,
zu viele Wahlmöglichkeiten –
darauf reagieren wir
auf zwei verschiedene Arten:
Zum einen mit dauernder Wachsamkeit
und Hypersensibilität.
Man hält es ohne ständig neuen Input
gar nicht mehr mit sich selbst aus.
Der Stresslevel steigt und damit die Angst,
etwas Wichtiges zu übersehen
oder etwas Interessantes zu verpassen.
Andere stumpfen ab,
interessieren sich für nichts mehr,
überlassen sich der Flut der bunten Bilder.
Unter Stress werden wir einerseits
vergesslich und unkonzentrierter.
Was mir besonders Sorge macht, ist,
dass wir anfangen, stärker zu polarisieren.
Das heißt, wir unterscheiden mehr in
Schwarz-Weiß.
Wir nehmen Situationen schneller
als bedrohlich wahr.
Das heißt, durch die Überforderung,
die entsteht, fangen Menschen auch an,
in so ’nen Modus zu kommen,
wo sie schneller angreifen, schneller streiten.
Dr. Jan Kalbitzer ist Facharzt
für Psychiatrie und Psychotherapie.
Er forscht am Zentrum für Internet
und seelische Gesundheit der Charité Berlin.
Menschen wollen wissen,
was in ihrer Umwelt los ist,
und durch diesen ständigen Nachrichtenfluss,
diesen ständigen Alarmismus
in den Nachrichten verstärkt sich
eine Angst der Menschen vor dem Internet
oder auch vor der Welt da draußen.
Es ist schon,
als ob wir in der virtuellen Realität leben.
Wir gehen durch eine
wahnsinnig sichere Stadt
und haben dauernd Angst, weil wir überflutet
werden mit gefährlichen Nachrichten.
Im Internet gibt es zu jeder Meinung
eine Gegenmeinung.
Manchmal ist es fast unmöglich,
Fakten von Fake News zu unterscheiden –
und weit und breit niemand, der das Chaos
für uns durchschaubarer machen kann.
Die Suchmaschinen,
denen wir uns anvertrauen,
suchen uns schließlich nicht die besten,
sondern die am besten bezahlten
Informationen heraus.
Das ist ’n großes Problem, wenn wir alles,
was im Internet ist, über Geld regulieren.
Das darf nicht mehr stattfinden.
Wir müssen als Gesellschaft
viel stärker da eingreifen,
politisch, aber auch jeder Einzelne.
Das Internet verändert unser Gehirn,
auch strukturell.
Es gibt Forschungsergebnisse,
die darauf hindeuten,
dass das tägliche Computer-Multitasking
zu einer schlechteren Verschaltung
im frontalen Cortex führt.
Gleichzeitig ist zum Beispiel
der Teil des sensomotorischen Cortex’,
der zuständig ist für die Daumenbewegung,
bei den heute 15-Jährigen
doppelt so groß wie bei ihren Eltern.
Man kann also nicht einfach behaupten,
das Internet würde uns dümmer machen.
Als Menschen angefangen haben,
im Gegensatz zu den Affen
den Daumen der Hand gegenüberzustellen
und Werkzeuge zu benutzen,
da hat das unser Gehirn auch
komplett verändert in seiner Struktur.
Auf einmal sind wir viel aufrechter gegangen,
um die Hand besser nutzen zu können.
Das Gehirn verändert sich permanent,
und das muss es auch.
Es muss sich ja
neuen Umweltveränderungen anpassen.
Die Frage ist also viel eher, wie wir Wissen
besser für uns organisieren können.
Ob man sich nun selbst
eine Informationsdiät verordnet
oder gemeinsam mit Freunden
und Familie überlegt,
wie man stressfreier durchs Internet kommt –
Medienkompetenz brauchen heute alle.